if you type in steven crowder change my
mind
seems pretty specific yeah all of the
first page video results are from other
channels not some all of them so moving
on to YouTube here really quickly and by
the way before we talk about any of this
please do just bookmark this page check
in and every day we do a new video every
single day just check in every night if
you're not a member of Mudd Club because
a lot of these changes are making it
harder for us to reach you the
subscribers to reach you people who've
already chosen to watch this content so
we've uncovered some some new alarming
information about the YouTube policy
changes over the last few weeks and we
knew that leading up to 2020 election
big tech they were gonna try and sway
things for Democrats this comes from
leaked videos memos whistleblowers they
all showed us that Silicon Valley was
devastated by Trump's win and they were
openly determined to not let it happen
again I certainly find the selection
deeply offensive and I know many of you
do too
it's too bad it's a very stressful time
and it conflicts with many of our values
what they're really saying about
fairness is that they have to manipulate
their search results so it gives them
the Caitlyn Jenner everything then she
ran over school of small children huh
how is by the way a democratic election
offensive my mom was elected oh okay
well it's not my guy but I was like that
is offensive right
it does make any sense I'm he didn't
walk up but he he didn't try to pork my
mom I think you should maybe I don't the
job I don't stand by it at all he I know
he's completely straight he's never
dealt there and back during the Vox ad
pocalypse days we talked about we warned
that YouTube would be seeking censorship
not just D monetization or banning which
everyone can see but more pervasive less
noticeable ways bringing awareness or at
least if you're not already aware you
need to make yourself aware and then
bringing as much awareness as possible
as you can to as many people as possible
yeah to the most severe
form of censorship the invisible
censorship that occurs it's just muffled
so that can essentially cut your views
in half or down to ten it's an invisible
rule invisible punishment of that rule I
think we're going to see more of this
kind of censorship because it goes
unnoticed therefore it has less
possibility of bad publicity for YouTube
so I just tossed it's good clip of
myself yeah yeah it's like meta it's
like the inception of low-budget late
night me when I see that horrible Lilly
Singh makes corner salary than our
entire budget hugs with a fraction of
the viewership
so let's brown and buy so Solan brave I
just wish you'd get an open mic first so
a couple of points here a little bit let
me kind of this is hard because people
who don't necessarily work in the
industry often hear the cries from
conservatives and we've talked about
this efficiently they're often overblown
right you can't just talk about what you
want YouTube to be you need to hold
their feet to the fire of what they
claim YouTube is right YouTube they've
said that they are going to make it
easier for people to find content from
verified channels okay that that was the
most recent rollout they've done the
exact opposite yeah this is alarming
because it can happen to anyone this is
how a normal YouTube search works kay
let me walk you through this let's say
you search for jenna Marbles yes her
video pops up and it's these are the
first results all the videos are from
her channel but right now and this may
change if you're watching this unless
you have a time machine right because
videos got forever right now at the
moment of this taping if you search
steven crowder our channel may pop up
but we're blacklisted from the video
results the first video result from this
channel is almost 70 videos in that's
multiple pages of results if you type in
my name and the name of this channel
let's get a little more specific you can
say well I don't know maybe you guys
suck at SEO fair let's say you want and
this is how we found out because one of
our researchers reg was trying to tell a
friend oh yeah if you want to watch the
chip just search steven crowder changed
my mind it'll pop right up well I did a
little experiment if you type in steven
crowder change my mind
seems pretty specific yeah all of the
first page video results are from other
channels not some all of them with fewer
views by the way with
a few reviews and it's not just some of
them are taking you to to like local CBS
affiliates we want to hear they want to
hear what Schenectady had to say and
here are a couple of students I don't
like it back to you bill
intrepid rhetoric was interesting about
that is the the idea that when you go
through and do the searches I mean I you
know on YouTube every day and kind of
looking through those things and
monitoring them and no matter what you
search for them no matter what browser
whether you've cleared your cookies
whether you're on someone else's phone
or their device I've tested it on many
devices and having many people do it and
it all comes up the same you're gonna go
constantly the the crowder videos and
the shows videos are constantly going to
the bottom of the search results
anywhere from ten to a hundred before
you get to an actual Steve and outer
Channel video and by the way this isn't
just if that's what we've talked about
the blacklist of 2020 election results
we want you to understand that it's
about more than just us but that being
said and I don't ever want to sound
braggadocious I'm incredibly humbled and
grateful this is the biggest
conservative channel that's ever existed
on YouTube and they declared that we had
never violated policies right so that's
where we stand if the biggest
conservative channel that's ever existed
that never violated policies according
to YouTube CEO Susan Wojcicki can be
throttled this way they can do it to
anyone what do you think they'll do to
smaller channels may think you're not
looking by the way we ran some other
searches this is why we want you to a
grenade
live action has the same thing Paul
Joseph Watson who will be on next has
the same problem Lauren Chen Breitbart
news same issue yeah what's the effect
what's the net effect our weekly views
and subscribers ship gains have dropped
dramatically dramatically here you can
see this area here's the thing though
that's important to note because I know
a lot of you said well you're just
pissed that people don't want to tune in
to your channel anymore and that's valid
sometimes people just get you know the
thing is you are not tuning out you guys
have still been subscribed you've been
bookmarking the page checking in every
day here's the number of the matters all
of the videos on a per video basis the
views are still growing yeah yeah we
have more people watching individual
videos than ever before we're getting 10
to 20 times as many views as The Young
Turks are Seth Meyers and her a video
pound-for-pound basis the only thing
that's gone down are the views and
organic subscriptions from search so
this is what's happened
yes we have more people our videos are
averaging close to a million which is on
the same considering our subscribers
thank you so much really engage we
really appreciate it but mark the page
but think about that for a second we
only eat what we've already killed and
gained ourselves yeah we can get no new
fans we can get no new eyeballs on our
content through organic search because
of the blacklisting they can do that if
they want but it's the opposite of what
they said they were going to do they
held a press conference say it was going
to be the opposite of this we're
verified yeah they direct people away
from right and it's so and it's so
obvious whenever I go and search for
Stephen crowd or anything I'm not
looking for John and his basement
commenting on a video that you did that
has 56 views there's no logical reason
that your stuff shouldn't come up
especially with the number of views like
if we had a thousand views on our videos
which we don't okay fine maybe it gets
lost in the wash maybe we're like
everybody else that's not the case
there's no explanation for it at all
other than them wanting your content
we're going to get in some more kind of
legal developments here with that we'll
bring them into it well bring them into
the guest chair so yeah oh wow I've
never worn a guest chair this isn't it's
not whether there are rules and by the
way the rules aren't followed at all but
the rules are not applied equally right
we've talked about them this show it's
not whether a country at it has a rule
of law it's whether the rule of law is
applied equally justice is applied
equally right now we search similar
left-wing channels hmm nothing like it
Young Turks can celebrate Dan Crenshaw's
I getting blown out and apparently I
[ __ ] by terrorists heroes with IEDs
this is from act he's a word for words
we're just a quote I don't want them
banned I don't want them throttled by
the way and when you search you only get
videos from their channel right same
thing if you search other leftist
late-night shows you only get results
from their channel something out of that
this will affect everybody these changes
by themselves may not seem so drastic
but when you add it all up and you go
through the history that we've had with
YouTube specifically we just have more
data than most people we want to make
you aware it does get to be pretty
sinister there are no more live
subscriber counts yeah right so Susan
Wojcicki she's she's always saying that
the company has been striving again not
what we want from YouTube what they
claim that they're striving for more
transparency on the platform we try to
be really transparent with our community
with our guidelines we do get the
requests for transparency and where we
are
working to continue to be more
transparent and explain working that's
comedy violation of our policies are not
opposition we're gonna have to change
that clip because to be fair that was
just her up talking about Jeffrey
Tambor's latest season fair point but
you know what I love how she the
carefully worded there we're working on
it working it working on it we're one
thing you can hold it to right now and
hold the mic you know your eyesight's I
know though because in case they may
have forgotten it got to prioritize you
know though you know the tens or
hundreds of emails and communications
we've sent saying all we need you to do
is just tell us just just just kind of
roughly point in the direction of what
we've done wrong right essentially
everything essentially what they've said
is like there's something wrong no
there's nothing wrong but some people
think there is so you can make no more
money well you know what's become
interesting is the D monetization has
become the trumpet right those now they
have said oh well look we've taken
action even though we went back and re
reviewed we said there was no violation
but then everyone was really upset so we
went ahead and reinterpreted the rice so
that we could do some kind of punishment
and now look we've done the punishment
and that's all we've done what but yet
behind the scenes this is the issue
there's lizard mark we've been
demonetized please yeah I would say
subscribe that the notification belt
join up at Mudd Club if you want the
show to not go away this is the only
thing that we have Mudd Club and a
couple of sponsors every now and then
but bookmark the page and check in every
day because notifications don't always
work okay it could go away there's a lot
that's happening behind the scenes
beyond the monetization borderline
material they've never defined it it's
an invisible rule was invisible
punishment but YouTube they've now made
the platform even less transparent with
no more live subscriber count' look at
this right now why would they do this
why would they make it less transparent
because they want to make it more
difficult to see how this blacklisting a
shadow banning is having an effect so
they said we want to direct people to
verify channels we can tell you
objectively they're doing the opposite
and they've removed the ability for it
not just you publicly I think a lot of
you assume that we have some tools that
we don't we can't see whether you're
subscribing yeah we can't see what's
happening with our subscribers how long
you're staying they've made it harder
that's incredible so they're becoming
essentially some of the worst
propagandist machines that we've seen
throughout history and they're doing it
under the guise of work for you or for
the community right for helping
everybody out but this is just
propaganda what if it was the other way
around
what if only right-wing content was
going on right and that was it and
left-wing was being muted and and here's
something else that's really unnerving
for me we don't know what it's going to
be yet there's an incoming new
harassment policy they're planning in
response by the way to the Vox had
pocalypse so I'm sorry that this
happened to the rest of you we weren't
looking for the ad pocalypse nope they
drew first blood not me but from CNBC
Yeah right says the new update comes
just after Vox journalist Carlos maza
beautiful hombre former that's spoke out
in May about harassment he said he
experienced on the platform at the hands
of conservative commentator Steven
Treader after flip-flopping on his
policy YouTube ultimately has said days
later that would take a hard look at our
harassment policies with an aim to
update them okay so what constitutes
harassment hmm and I know what why don't
you sit down with your biggest
conservative channel let us know exactly
we just yet we reached out to by a guy
named Brandon Brandon Brandon we've
taught you've spoken with Susan Wojcicki
in the top brass at YouTube we have even
met at random no no Brandon a gentleman
named Brandon and know he would be yet
another person who I'm sure will tell us
yes something's happening and don't
worry we're gonna see the information
but we just don't have enough people
working here we don't have enough skill
to pull the data Brad you're asking we
don't have enough people to be put on
the biggest controversy of the year as
it relates to content guidelines the
number one concern so you know you're
just you're on the back burner here's
Brandon well what does he know Brandon
tell them I don't know I'm an intern
what do I know I make it clear publish
the guidelines and we'll play ball
listen if you tip if you're if you're a
publisher you're not a private but
you're not an open platform then make it
clear what you'll publish
yeah that's what we just want to
understand your rules so we know how to
play by them we can put the more
controversial content like I don't know
criticizing anyone on the LGBTQ move we
can put that behind mug club and make
sure there's just vanilla milk toast
here on YouTube but you said you don't
want that because you're an open
platform yeah let us know and then we
know how we can move forward and let's
find common ground
that's what we're looking for and you
know what let's move a half-asian alert
bill Richmond let's move them over here
so we can talk about my legal action
yeah come on over and they're just
keeping in an ever moving target right
it's just makes it so much easier for
them to hem and haw and say oh we're
just gonna kind of go with the wind here
and make it an ever moving target so
there's no actual policy right so have
it you know half-asian thank you
wonderful sponsor well everyone out
there try the Walter I just don't want
it aimed at my half-asian lawyers
scrotum and testicles crutch as small as
they may be what is it that we need to
do what actions are we we're going to be
taking because it's reach beyond the
point of just complaining well the you
know it's what's what's amazing about
this the every time we think you know
certainly this is the dumbest move that
YouTube is gonna make or this is the
last action they're gonna take behind
the curtain or to you know take
invisible action behind to do something
especially considering them as steps
from the Vox ad pocalypse they continue
to do more and some of the most recent
things that you've seen and that we
talked about just now are you know the
the changes behind the scenes that are
only affecting not only louder with
crowd or but are affecting a whole slew
of conservative voices and as opposed to
leftist voices and when we have reached
out continuously we haven't seen
anything haven't gotten that information
and so the next steps are going to
evolve a kind of multi-faceted one we
already know that there's an existing
lawsuit that's been going on from
leftist groups and specifically LGBT
groups and you know for those who may be
watching who are concerned about well
you know hey you know what I actually
don't care if you get throttled but
don't think about it of just this view
think about it if anyone can throttle
any political problem with the LGBTQ
lawsuit does they want an injunction so
that you cannot throttle them but they
also want YouTube to have more strict
policies regarding hate speech to create
a more safe safe space everybody them
just not us and that's the crazy part
about their their lawsuit is the
inconsistency there and don't ban us but
make sure to ban other people but the
one part that they do get right and that
they go after YouTube for is the
inconsistency and the lack of clarity
about what the policies are time and
time again so we're gonna take some
action there decide the right time to be
able to you jump into the fray on that
side and go to the part that really is
an important point because it does
affect everyone any political view
so I think more important than just
political views people that understand
YouTube is the central business model
for a lot of content creators yeah let's
remove politics from it this is how many
people make a living and don't make a
living directly on the monetization on
YouTube you use YouTube as an avenue to
reach people jumping-off point the
biggest biggest expense this company has
ever had outside of employee costs has
been running advertising on YouTube for
long time they courted us and said they
created the advertising campaigns
millions of dollars yeah and that's
what's crazy is that you know folks will
always say well you could just go to a
different platform you could just do
something different but they forget that
all of the creators especially louder
Crowder has spent in in you know
innumerable hours learning the system
working on it over the years building a
subscriber base they can't just follow
anywhere else and by the way flying out
at their dime flying out to YouTube
convert this is important for you to
know half-asian bill Richman went out
with to a conference spoke with Susan
Wojcicki before that I went out and
spoke with their top legal we spoke with
their people in charge of content folks
in their legal they invited us and when
we were there constant conversation was
water that what are the guidelines what
well what are we are we violating
anything no no no no no not at all we
want diverse voices then when we leave
the conference's we see a different
story playing and policies changed
without us knowing exactly and it's
either it's either their their stories
either gonna be were been doing this
deliberately or it's gonna be we just
didn't know what was happening and that
may be kind of reminiscent of the
Facebook yeah battle that actually
brought us together that the idea that
oh well it's just some rogue employees
put a policy together the black listed a
few conservative voices and was going on
for years and nobody knew about it up
top real sorry right but you did just we
are going to be taking action so yes so
some of the action is of course you know
we can go out to a certain extent about
that is but there's multifaceted it's
not just action we'll take directly but
the thing that you did in the call to
action to be able to say hey you know
pull up the examples your own favorite
conservative channels your second favor
beyond a lot of times do did you if you
want to help them and you want to help
us you want to help anyone who has a
political view whether it's conservative
or otherwise to force YouTube here's the
thing as we know they're listening
remember back to the Vox ad pocalypse
within a day even less than a day of He
Who Shall Not Be Named who's beautiful a
brave brave
hosted about a complaint just a mere
complaint we want how many zillions of
complaints they get and they knew that
that happened and they immediately took
action worked all weekend review all
your videos and now we can we get a
reach out again who this person is and
what they're actually a cell phone video
that hit a million plays yes what's so
sad and listen it saddens me that that I
mean I'm grateful that we have this
platform it but I think of people where
I was maybe six years ago you know it's
trying to grind it out you guys aren't
gonna be able to make enough of a stink
with the view count for YouTube to
answer I have a lawyer on retainer
you're very expensive by the way we have
to stop that wing in the new beach house
and he can't get return calls what gets
a point of contact is me putting a cell
phone video out and you guys sending in
screenshots so please keep doing then
then I guess we'll try and talk with
Brendan Brandon Brandon not Brenda who
you are Brandon well here's in here know
it's nothing personal I want to talk to
the manager give me the manager my name
is Karen is so the the idea that we're
not listening or they're unable to
respond or be able to do anything that's
crazy but what they do respond to is
think about all the comments that the
folks have put on to you know the videos
and on to tweets that have been able to
have and not only that the folks who
continually and repeatedly say you know
what this is the moment that I've joined
mug Club and then a post about joining
mug Club right directly if they're not
gonna listen to the following their own
guidelines if they're if YouTube isn't
gonna listen to just being
intellectually honest they're definitely
gonna listen when you hit their
pocketbook and let them know that
they're gonna have to go to a different
place where they know they can get the
content well thank you very much how
efficient builders been and just so you
know we are going to be taking legal
action we can't talk about it a ton
right now because with something like
this and I see a lot of conservative
lawsuits where they just file them file
them file we're not litigious people
it's it's bet once and that right and so
the more information you can provide to
us we really appreciate it this is
something else to keep in mind they're
not only trying to alter the results of
the 2020 election which they've openly
expressed this is this is YouTube also
being upset about Generation Z being
more conservative than other generations
in part because of social media and I
don't mean not all generations II folks
are conservatives that's not I'm saying
right but if you compare them at this
stage in their life to baby boomers to
Gen Xers they are more conserve
and a big part of that is because of
social media you look at First Amendment
you look at Second Amendment issues you
look at neo feminist issues this is
because the left is overreached and now
they have access to the information so
by the way Silicon Valley calls this
radicalization what are they consider
radicalization that's why we're
radicalizing the youth apparently along
with philip defranco if you look at that
New York Times article radicalization is
apparently using someone's biologically
correct pronouns big tech wants to
change an entire worldview of a
generation that's why they don't want
you to see change my mind and here's the
if you can think of anything more benign
when people go out and preach hey let's
find common ground let's stop the
shouting matches let's stop the cable
news hyper edits where we're just
looking to score points if you can think
anything that crystallizes that more
effectively than change my mind
completely unedited on a campus with
students who are there of their own
volition you let me know because if
that's if change my mind is considered
radicalization to the point that YouTube
is going to try and ghost it from search
results well you know what I guess I'm
the radicalize ER of the youth and I'll
wear that title proudly hey there
youtube viewer you know the drill just
click one of these other videos in a box
playing up here and I mean by there's an
actual box I don't of course mean that
in the feminine it's a slur but that of
course I don't mean box because men can
have boxes too and I don't mean to say
box I just that men can there's like a
DC outlet an AC outlet and they can be
either one that they choose depending on
the electrical current or tha'ts charge
of ions I think